welcome to the ichi live oscars
afterparty i'm denny directive and i'm
cassie - laura waters a show cheers oh
the Oscars Oscars the end of awards
season and what a way to go out with a
bang I mean what a historical night for
women for diversity really we're marvel
I first Oscar as did Spike Lee's Regina
King a lot of firsts nice we're gonna
get into all of that guys giving you a
full recap of the 91st annual Academy
Awards the big moments of the night's
the big shockers and if there were one
big one was a big one which we're gonna
get to in just a few we're gonna break
that all down for you guys right now
but first let's break down the Best
Picture winner taking home one of the
most coveted Awards of the night to no
one's surprise
Green buck I will say it's only
surprising in the sense that I truly
feel that the eight nominees for Best
Picture anyone could have taken it it
was kind of hard to call you know you
had Roma and the favorite leading with
10 you had a blockbuster like Black
Panther which was also culturally
tonight I will say as the Bohemian
Rhapsody right I also got a lot of love
I believe they won for four Academy
Awards so a lot of momentum leading up
to it but Green Book ultimately took it
it was a category that obviously the
competition was stiff but I don't know I
mean obviously we we've we've discussed
this movie through our awards season and
I first you know this was always the
front-runner at least for me and now I
loved it now I'm kicking myself in the
head because I didn't have time to put
together my Oscars and I literally would
have taken home all of the money we're
cept except for lead actress that's like
one of the only ones that I would have
gotten wrong but like I said Green Book
was anticipated well let's get into that
shocker actually because I will say guys
Olivia Colman performance in the
favorite was amazing but a lot of people
had their money on Glenn Close so if you
bet on her in Vegas
I apologize for you you just lost some
money I mean I truly thought Glenn was
gonna be awarded that long overdue
career awesome this was her seventh
nomination for
she had won at the Golden Globes she has
she slept exactly swept on like she did
not win today what she you know we joke
about it but it's the truth of it is is
she's kind of that case of always a
bridesmaid never a bride she in her face
when they announce Olivia Colman as the
winner she was shocked too yeah like we
have a look at a clip in case you guys
missed it here's Olivia Colman finding
out that she just won an Oscar and the
Oscar goes to
Olivia Colman
this is the first Oscar and nomination
for Olivia Colman knees for the Queen I
must start literally
Emma Stone was in tears the best part is
is that you know the whole beginning of
her speech she literally could not get
her words together rightfully so though
imagine how much how you're overcome
with emotion and she had tears streaming
down her face because she genuinely did
not expect this because I feel like
Olivia just like the rest of us probably
thought Glenn was gonna win but Glenn
did that very good gracious like here's
the thing you know who won or you know
who knew all along that Olivia Colman
was gonna win Melissa McCarthy okay you
know why rocking the rabbit that's the
beginning of the show she's more shadow
that she was literally wearing the
rabbits Queen Anne's rather I love it I
only did Olivia Colman when best actress
I think she won best speech - it was so
emotional it was so fun but someone else
who gave an equally amazing acceptance
speech tonight was Rami Malek he took
home his first actor for Best Actor in a
leading role as a Freddie Mercury and
Bohemian Rhapsody I was really really
stoked for him this was one that we've
called since the beginning I mean the
transformation how hard and how
committed he was to this role and what I
find fascinating is Rami has said in
previous interviews that he you know he
went into this role not knowing much
about Queen and look what he did with
this movie and now he has taken home an
Oscar for it and of course rightfully so
he had you know someone very special and
a band very special to thank in his
acceptance speech I do believe we have a
little clip of that thank you guys for
being for allowing me to be the tiniest
part of your phenomenal extraordinary
legacy I am forever in your debt
ladies a big deal for several reasons he
think Lucy Boynton who was his co-star
in Bohemian Rhapsody that's where they
met they fell in love they've been kind
of low-key up until tonight oh we
planted one
he was multiple times and he was like
literally they depressed together on the
red carpet at the Oscars and he's Kevin
Frazier and Nancy O'Dell who were on the
red carpet spoke to both of them again
first time they've really kind of
acknowledged that they are an item and
acknowledged her in his speech said
quote quote you captured my heart that
was the moment where Denny and I grabbed
each other's hands because we're like we
don't have a significant other or an
Oscar but rami malek does look he comes
out of that that movie with an Oscar and
a relationship you are living your best
life Rob good also real quick he also
mentioned that he's a first generation
American and it was so inspiring him
saying that his story is still being
written right now and if all you
dreamers out there keep on dreaming all
right someone who's dreaming who has
dreamed a dream I should say and has
come out the end a winner is Lady Gaga
Lady gaga a huge night for her obviously
one of the most highly anticipated
moments of the night her performance of
shallow with Bradley Cooper I mean I am
off the deep end over here I don't even
think you and I have good chemistry but
nothing compares Bradley and Lady Gaga
attention the closeness attention to all
of it I thought they were gonna kiss you
know that let's take a look at their
performance of shouts night at the
Oscars
[Music]
here Michelle
[Music]
I mean this is really close performance
of Shalott which took a home Best
Original Song
but are we surprised never looks so good
that was a hot performance Bradley
Cooper's vocals were a little shaky
let's be real but of course
listen I've called this from the
beginning we got to nominate him for ACM
new artist of the year CMT CMA gives and
he does have a Grammy to his name now
thanks again I do love though that at
the very end of his performance he knew
he like nailed it and did this cute
little moment at the side where he's yes
pressure performing even need an
introduction
no they literally just started before he
walked up onto the stage and those who
were inside the Dolby theater said that
when after their performance when they
came back out to get into their seats
there was a standing ovation and people
have said that they've never seen that
before for breaks they came back and the
love was still there well like I
mentioned Gaga earned Bradley his first
Grammy and Bradley got Gaga her first
Oscar because she took home Best
Original Song dream team I mean truly
her speech was also amazing because she
shared that you know I've been working
hard for a very very long time and she
told all those kids watching and like
keep on working keep on chasing that's
why I said at the beginning I said you
know she's dreamed a dream and actually
a part of her speech was it's not about
winning it's about not giving up if you
have a dream fight for it there's a
discipline for passion and it's not
about how many times you get rejected or
you fall down or you're beaten up it's
about how many times you stand up and
are brave and you keep on going you
heard those are Lady Gaga's words not
mine
well it's like they're yours I love she
evokes that energy she's inspiring he's
inspiring that film was inspiring you
know the one else who has an Oscar and
who is inspiring Best Supporting Actress
winner she kicked off
the night miss Regina King she won for
her role in if Bill Street could talk
first nomination for her check mark
right next to that got that win for a
role like this film was her first film
in 10 years
she's busy collecting Emmys that's why
she's busy collecting Emmys on the TV
side it was kind of amazing to see her
I'm not only win but also represent that
film because I loved if Bill Street
could talk and I felt like it was robbed
of a Best Picture nomination so I loved
it has won to its name now and I will
say I loved her speech which was she she
thanked her family she thinks her mom
who was there right by her side and that
was kind of a theme that we saw
throughout the night a lot of people
thinking whether it's your mother your
father your grandmother I heard a lot of
grandmothers think tonight but I do
believe we have a little clip of that
we're going to show it to you and the
Oscar goes to Regina
I'm an example of what it looks like
when support and love is poured into
someone mom don't love you so much
no it's not just her mom and all of us
showering Regina King with love people
in the audience - who got your back girl
because the moment everybody is talking
about that's trending on Twitter is
after Regina King won she needed a
little help up those stairs and who
stepped in no no none other than Captain
America himself you know chivalry is not
dead she's not done especially with
Chris Evans but what I love I will I
want to point out really quick is Regina
King looked unbelievable on that white
dress and when she hit the red carpet
all of us in this newsroom were like us
she knows she's winning that's a winners
dress right there she knew she what she
was wearing what she looked like a
superhero and then in the arms of
another with Chris Evans I know there
was some hilarious tweets and Twitter
reactions to that moment here's the
first one Chris Evans the real-life
Captain America here he came to the
rescue there he sure did another one you
guys one of my favorites get you a man
that looks at you the way Chris Evans
looks at Regina King's mom oh gotta give
the mom some love - I love it see like I
said chivalry is not dead with him he he
respects the mothers he escorts you up
the stairs he's the guy you want to take
home right
another big trending moment of the night
because again guys remember this was the
first Oscars without a host since 1989
what they do it well they have the help
of a lot of comedians who presented
tonight one of my favorite moments was
Melissa McCarthy and Brian Tyree Henry
presenting in the costume some of the
costumes nominated for outstanding
costume design there they are right
there
Melissa dressed as Queen Anne from the
favorite with all the rabbits with the
rabbits I'm telling you that's what
manifested olivia's which was a good
luck charm
you got playing tyree Henry who has like
the Mary Poppins vibe also
maybe the favorite and black panther
makeup like all of it it was hilarious
we were not the only ones who absolutely
loved this I do believe we have some
tweets from social media that kind of
captured all of our emotions with this
little skit right here someone said oh
my god Melissa McCarthy just provided
eternal justification for keeping costly
design in the broadcast Jordan right
there she the referring to the
controversial decision to air that
almost there's some categories they were
going to announce during commercial
break I'm so glad they didn't Rob Thomas
also tweeted at least with no host they
have the genius of people like Melissa
McCarthy to bring some great life to the
show and I share his sentiment Melissa
McCarthy who by the way was on the red
carpet full Hollywood glam she's also
nominated for Best Actress but she's not
above throwing on a wig some crazy
makeup and just giving us an awesome
comedic moments um one on Twitter
literally said that was the moment of
the night they said who needs a host
when you've got Melissa McCarthy's bunny
well also guys thankfully there was it
was jam-packed with performances no
Kendrick Lamar says et confirmed earlier
this week that they would not be
performing their nominated song all the
stars but what we did get was a killer
opening number courtesy of Adam Lambert
with Queen of course in honor of
Bohemian Rhapsody they opened the the
show with we will rock you it was so
good it was good right okay another
favorite moment ours again this is why
we don't need a host because you have
people like Maya Rudolph Tina Fey and
Amy Poehler they hit the stage to give I
guess a quote unquote opening monologue
because they were the first people out
on the stage after Queens performance
but they really were hilarious
presenting Best Supporting Actress I do
believe we have a little clip of it so
just a quick update for everybody in
case you're confused there is no host
tonight there won't be a popular movie
category and Mexico is not paying for
the wall they were so funny so Maya
Rudolph she made a joke to chadwick
boseman of black panthers she goes what
kind of plans you got later
we're kinda Joe shot hey we're so it's
so funny about those three there's
there's such a triple-threat but they
you know they could be Oscars host and a
lot of people on social media said wait
you mean to tell me they're not they're
not hosting the rest of the evening
we're so enamored with them and we know
Tina Fey and I pull her good together
they hosted the Golden Globes three
years back to back so I mean I will make
the argument though that I could see the
Oscars without a host moving forward I
was having this one I will say I did not
miss any not having hosts this year I
think each person who presented who had
their moment on stage gave us a moment
you had samuel l.jackson joking about
the Knicks winning you had Aquafina who
could rightfully so also be a host in
the future I feel like there was no
forced humor mhm I'm the audience it was
just it was very organic and I don't
think we needed a host I agree with you
I even Jimmy Kimmel tweeted something
told you they're not gonna call me to
come right let's get into who won Best
Director though this one kind of was
there was a favorite to win there was a
surprise on winning Best Director for
Romo
not at all no and of course Romo was
leading the night tied for most Oscar
nominations at 10:00 they are tied with
the favorite if there was one to lose it
was gonna be this one like we knew
Alfonso we're gonna win he also won the
same trophy for directing gravity but it
was nice to see Romo get a little love
and someone else who got a little love
tonight Spike Lee winning his first
Oscar which I could not believe adapted
screenplay you couldn't believe it see
act he doesn't have an Oscar right I
could not believe it and it was his
first nomination for Best Picture and
Best Director but it was nice in him
walk away with some hardware and he took
the opportunity new new Spike Lee was
gonna do this going into it he had a
whole speech he had longer receives than
I do his his which was ready and it was
planned he you know drew attention to
the upcoming presidential election he
goes you knew
was gonna say something he said do the
right thing and I got off I got the
moral decision of love versus hate I
actually do believe we have a clip okay
I take a look
Tatchell the word today is irony the
date the 24th the month February which
also happens to be the shortest month of
the year which old happens to be Black
History Month the year 2019 the year
1619 history herstory
1619 2019 Spike Lee right there winning
his first Oscar for Best Adapted
Screenplay and really taking the moment
as you mentioned cast to share an
important message do you know we were
all happy for him as with samuel
l.jackson they're so excited for each
other I mean obviously Spike Lee's
making history tonight
and and Samuel Jackson has been a writer
die in his grave for a really really
long time I was so stoked for this
moment and I think I got one of the
loudest applause of the night for him
yeah well we've been talking about the
big moments throughout the night now we
got now we got to throw some fashion and
there we talked about fashion about the
fashion to me so are you we're just in
our Sunday best over here bringing out
this sequin someone else who brought out
the seagulls you guys talking about some
memorable Oscar outfits Emma Stone in a
custom Moo Eva town Louie Vuitton gown
oh my gosh do not kill me al Viva oh
saying Louis Vuitton wrong I'm she was
also wearing Louis Vuitton jewelry as
well would you guys think of this I
think it was perfect for her a new hair
color which I think I'm assuming it's
because she's shooting Zombieland - and
she has to go like with a darker thing
but she matched her dress even the
eyeliner if you look are scuse me
eyeshadow if you look I think it was it
was definitely on the best-dressed list
I agree someone else who was on the
best-dressed list and giving em a little
run for her money was Michelle Yeoh from
crazy rich Asians you guys see this
gorgeous ally Saab down I mean she
looked so regal in it as you would say
she looks rich
and that's not a pun of crazy rich
Asians she just looks exquisite and
expensive like that's funny like do you
see the jewels on that is show part
jewelry ah and I'm blind dangling from
her ears I mean he's just crushing it it
was something else another big moment
that everyone was talking about was best
animated film that went to again another
one I was not surprised by but a lot of
people were rallying behind it including
our girls crossing crossing I know you
were excited for this spider-man into
the spider-verse won for Best Animated
Film is actually the second time a
spider movie has received an Oscar
spider-man 2 won for Best Visual Effects
back in the day but I don't think you
can compare these two no not of course
it's hailed for its inspiring story and
the fresh visual style but this was one
that when they were reading off the
nominations I mean you could just hear
it in the room as soon as it was called
you could just hear the uproar and like
we said I should have put my money in
Vegas that's all right overall thoughts
of the Oscars no host a lot a lot of
history maker what'd you think good
fashioned happy for Olivia Colman that
was definitely the biggest shocker of
the night other than that I feel like it
kind of went on track on par whatever
you want to say there wasn't too many
surprises a lot of we're definitely
entertained by Lady gaga and Bradley
Cooper's performance of shallow I mean
it was just an overall a really good
award show but it was historic there's
so many different reasons and I want to
shout out the ladies right there you
guys 15 wins tonight at the Oscars which
makes it the winningest night in Oscar
history the previous ceremonies in 2007
and 2015 had 12 wins so beat that record
so capable Rhea ditional wins incredible
some of the best speeches of the night I
mean a movie about what she say
menstruation won an Oscar like yes
diversity inclusion women it was just it
was it was a very empowering night
absolutely in speaking of superpowers
Marvel won their first Oscars tonight
courtesy of Black Panther and I got to
give a shout out to Ruthie Carter Atta
she won best costume design becoming the
first African American to win in that
category actually
I had the chance to visit her at her
home see the Black Panther sketches and
also costumes costume designs for other
Spike Lee movies and there was she had
costumes for Malcolm X and do the right
thing I mean I really got to see the
journey yeah she winning her first Oscar
so much to cheers and quit cheers the
rehearsal Ollie he's the second black
actor to win two Oscars so laughs as we
mentioned guys a lot of history makers
we are cheering you for an amazing
amazing night and thank you guys so much
for joining us we're gonna keep the
party going though so head over to the
live stream stick with us on ET live.com
you can also download our app we are
available on roku Apple TV Amazon fire
Android and iOS so stick with us for all
about the Oscars here on
[Music]